yes I'm delighted to say I'm joined by
two of the stars of this film Carey
Mulligan and Helena Bonham Carter lovely
to see you both
and now you've been joined on this red
carpet this evening I know Carrie you
didn't see it but Helen Lee you did but
by some protesters and they said that
they were inspired by the suffragettes
they've been lying on the red carpet we
do have sympathy for them to you because
it's quite inspiring
now I'm glad that our films done
something I think I film exactly that's
exactly what it's there for us but if
you feel strongly about and strongly
enough about something and there's an
injustice there there you can you can
speak out and you can try and get
something changed
that's it I'm it's a perfect response to
alpha I wish I'd see them I'm so annoyed
I'm a bit later if we went this is
exactly what I carriages yeah who would
do anyway that's it and a red car people
better think I'm it's better to lie down
and test them yeah they said exactly
that that if they've been separatist
they would have been here and they would
have been protesting about equality yeah
so great that's just so exciting people
have asked us same a time would you
protest now would you throw rock would
you you know and I keep thinking I wish
I could I would like to be as brave as
that for these women to do that tonight
both in your industry and in general how
equally Salafis I think bar industry is
sort of a microcosm of the world and in
general really isn't it so our society
is inherently sexist our industry is but
all
nature industry is I think you know 22
percent of women make up the Parliament
of a in the world and of all the
governing bodies 22 percent of female
and that's an enormous imbalance seems
to be corrected so I think we've got a
fair way to go this films a great
reflections gives us perspective on that
in a really great way it's not just a
documentary about the time it sort of
saying look this is what was achieved
but looking much further we need to go I
mean watching the film I was I was
invigorated and I and I got angry about
how far we've still got to go these
women started the fights in there it
actually made me feel how far we have
gone there's a lot that we can be we can
be angry about there's been a lot of
progress isn't surimi like this it also
gives us it gives us inspiration and it
gives us hope to carry on the fight and
there's a lot to be done and can be done
how do people feel passionately about
how much sexism of you experience I've
been remarkably lucky I was a bit like a
beast a beast said in an interview that
I read snappy Morgan a be known to the
writer I had a very I've had the luck of
geography is the one where I was born
and I was born see
inequality and it's completely absurd
that just because we've got the same
respect
I'm a mmm carry you easily Ward's users
with Emily practice words I would rather
be a rebel than a slave is cause some
offense can you understand why people
have been abundance but I think you know
the intention behind the shoes was
obviously to reflect the film which was
and how Emily thank us originally
intended a quote which was as a rallying
cry and obviously not intended to cause
any offense
but I think the discourse is great I
think you know should be a conversation
and it's and it should be an ongoing
conversation but you I would never want
that to overshadow the main intention of
the film and the intention of the
filmmakers which was to make a film to
empower people and not sort of ladies
thank you so much I'm congratulations to
Carey Mulligan who's just had a baby so
I'm still on the red carpet very
interested in the power so much